this is a production of cornell
university
all right uh thank you nina for the
introduction and thank you all for
joining me today for my seminar
uh again my name is brandon miller and
my presentation today is titled
hickories and horticulture
developing novel nursery crops
just a brief overview of what you can
expect from this presentation
i'm going to go over hickories and
horticulture the reasons why
horticulture should value them
and some of the problems that we
encounter with them in the nursery
industry
and i'll do this once i go over them
i'll talk about specific projects
that uh hone in on some of these
problems
that we've encountered and finding
solutions for them
and some of these projects i'll go over
in a little bit more detail than others
and then finally wrap it all up with
talking about the future research needs
what we need to continue to work on to
improve hickories in the nursery trade
some citations and of course my
acknowledgements now as dr basic
mentioned
my uh research that i've been working on
here at cornell
has been investigating approaches to
improve nursery production and
transplant success
and also looking at our understanding of
stress
tolerance mainly with hickories but also
with a handful of other
uh valuable plants for use in managed
landscapes but today we're going to talk
about
uh the projects i've worked on specific
to hickories
and just a little bit of overlap with
something that i've worked on with
birches and
and how those are tied together how
those connect
so uh getting started here why are we
talking about
these plants that we might use in
managed landscapes why are we
why are we interested in this at all and
really i'm approaching this from the
perspective that
uh trees in our managed landscapes trees
in our urban forests are threatened by
uh two main general factors biotic and
abiotic stresses
and in the most recent years especially
here in new york state
uh we've seen uh exotic invaders like
the spotted lanternfly and
the emerald ash borer insects that
threaten the stability
of our plantings and we also see
more dramatic weather patterns severe
weather events flooding drought
that our trees have to be able to
withstand all along the way and
our managed landscapes are particularly
vulnerable
when uh we have limited biodiversity so
the species that compose
our managed landscapes if uh if we have
if we don't have
a lot of biodiversity um they're
threatened by this and
and when that's the case if we do get
that specific pest
that favors that type of tree or the
conditions that threaten those trees
then this is what we end up with
and so we want to avoid that and the way
we do that is to bolster biodiversity
and look at other trees that we can add
to our plant palette
as options for biodiversification so one
of those groups of plants
that we would like to consider is are
the hickories now when i say
hickory species that belong to the genus
caria
many people probably are thinking about
shag bark hickory
it's one of the more iconic species it
has exfoliating plates exfoliating bark
beautiful golden fall color and edible
nuts
it has a pretty broad distribution and
so people from different regions
may often think of the species but what
people
don't often realize is that the genus
carrier is is more diverse than that
there are approximately 19 different
species depending on who your preferred
botanical authorities are
and the genus is broken up into three
groups three sub
genera the pecan hickories true
hickories and the asian hickories
and everything that i've put in this red
rectangle here these are all found
they're all endemic to north america
uh only one of them is restricted to
mexico
all the plants names that are in bold
there those can all be found
in the united states they're endemic to
the united states and so we can actually
look at the distribution of all of these
species on the generic level
if we look at the united states on the
county level so with the the counties
that are highlighted in green
those are counties where uh one of these
species of hickory can be found
and you can see it's a very broad
distribution i've drawn this red line
through so everything
to the east of that red line those are
native populations and everything to the
west are likely
naturalized populations where uh
people have moved these plants around
and they've
they've naturalized in those locations
but in the eastern united states
basically that whole half of the
united states there we can see that
there are species that range from
the furthest northern conditions to the
furthest southern conditions so we have
genetic variation that can accommodate
cold climates warm climates
coastal ecosystems there are
niche species that inhabit niche
ecosystems with
upland sites and wet riparian habitats
so
there's a lot of variation in this genus
and that means that
we have many traits that we can use to
our advantage in horticulture
and i'm mainly looking at these plants
from the ornamental perspective
or their use in managed landscapes but
other horticulturists may value them for
their nut production
or their other you know timber products
or
or other uh components so but there are
lots of reasons why we want to look at
them
uh when we're thinking about the
ornamental traits and some of these
useful
components and factors with hickories uh
one part that i like to talk about is
the bark because shag bark hickory
one of the more iconic species has that
exfoliating bark but not all the species
have that
uh there's a broad range of
characteristics that we find in the
genus
scaly flaky bark like we see with pecan
or fisher to bark
with some of the other species the
autumnal display
is uh is really something that many
horticulturists really favor with
hickories
they have a golden fall color and they
have some of the best golden fall
color of any temperate species that we
can find and so these are a handful of
taxa here with uh
more golden yellow or almost the amber
color like we see with pig nut hickory
i mentioned site adaptability and if you
look at the different species in this
genus you'll find plants that are on
uh upland sites some sites that tend to
be more dry
we see them in mesic sites you know
somewhere in between and then i
like i mentioned there are plants that
inhabit these niche riparian locations
rivers streams marshes and sometimes in
swamps
there are species that are adapted to
those locations
and growing habitats and if you look at
reference books if you ever look up
hickories uh oftentimes
terms like resilient uh will be used
with them and there really isn't a whole
lot of evidence for it
but we think of these plants as
adaptable and we suspect that they're
very resilient
and when we do see them in stressful
locations although rare
uh when we do find them they seem to do
particularly well
on sites that we would often think of as
challenging for most
trees i'd be missed not to mention their
fruit production
so they do produce edible nuts all the
species do but some are preferred more
than others
and pecan being a member of this genus
is a massive nut crop
not only in the united states but across
the the globe
and so many of these species are favored
by people for their edible nuts and
these trees are also the nuts in
particular
are consumed by other organisms not just
humans
because they're well adapted to the
entire eastern half of the united states
they're integral components to various
habitats and their ecological
significance
is uh is very important so we should
value these plants not only for our
personal use but
uh for their their role that they play
and the ecosystem
services that they provide
and so you may be wondering well if
these trees are so great why are we
talking about them today you know what's
the problem
and like anything else these trees are
not perfect
there are some issues in terms of
nursery production that
we could we could improve upon to make
these plants more viable
nursery crops and more accessible plants
for use in managed landscapes
and the three main groups are
transplanting propagation
and general production so there's some
kind of issue with these
areas that we need to address oftentimes
hickories are associated with their
strong dominant tap
root it is true that hickories do have a
strong tapper that persists beyond their
juvenile phase
and because they have this taproot many
horticulturists
you know they there's this
generalization that they cannot be
transplanted because they have this
strong taproot
um and and that's something that we're
trying to find evidence for determining
if that's true or if that's not
true but it is a generalization that's
made and common among nursery growers
and really you can see that taproot
development shortly after germination
hickories for the most part are produced
by seed and uh
right after germination you can tell
they put a lot of energy into the tap
root
and that investment in the tap root
persists for
uh their entire juvenile phase and that
juvenile phase can
you know it can vary from species to
species but it is multiple
years ultimately they put so much energy
into that taproot that the chute
the above ground portion is often
neglected and so from a nursery growers
perspective
if you have these teeny little sticks in
pots
uh you know it takes a long time to have
a saleable plant
and it's hard to make a profit so
nursery growers might shy away from them
just because
they are so slow to grow uh in their
juvenile lag phase
with their episodic shoot development
and because they're grown from seed when
growers do put in the time and energy
to invest in these plants and put them
in production we end up seeing a lot of
variability
so you might find plants like we see on
the left where they have a strong
uh apical dominance a nice form
these plants are six years old at a
nursery here in new york and
uh that plant on the left is saleable
but the two plants on the right
uh same age six years old have formed
more of a shrubby habit
and they're not the same size and
they're definitely not saleable so
this is an investment that many nursery
growers would shy away from
because you can't have that after six
years
so naturally then you would question
well why don't we asexually propagate
them have a more uniform crop
and while asexual propagation is
possible the techniques that are used
mainly for nut production they're just
not amenable
to nursery production for managed
landscapes from an ornamental
perspective
it could be that there's graft
incompatibility
or it could also just be that because
bark is one of those ornamental traits
we're interested in
these top grafted unions just are not
pleasing to the eye
and they're just not quite uh suited for
our our scope
so how do we take uh these plants that
we see on the left the small little shag
bark hickories and how do we
end up with a nice sailable plant that
is more common in the nursery trade and
then
you know more available to practitioners
i have a series of projects that i'm
going to go through the first three i'll
go through just a little bit more detail
with some
some brief data and then i'll just use
pictures to kind of describe the rest of
the work that i've been doing to try to
tie all this together the first project
i want to talk about is something that
we did trying to predict drought
tolerance trying to characterize drought
tolerance
of hickories i mentioned that sometimes
they're referred to as resilient
and so we want to actually put a number
to that determine where they fall
relative to other trees and our
hypotheses were
first that the species we studied the
riparian species might actually be more
drought tolerant
than the mesic upland counterparts
the reason for this is if you go to some
of these riparian habitats you'll see
that there's seasonal drought
that many of these habitats will go
through and so we wondered if perhaps
these plants are already adapted to the
fluctuations between
inundation and and drier conditions
and our second hypothesis was that the
degree of drought tolerance
would be variable within the species so
again
we're trying to quantify and
characterize drought tolerance we
studied a handful of
of species useful for northern uh
landscapes
and two inter-specific hybrids and then
we're just trying to get a better idea
of
how variable this trait is within and
across populations
so the species that we studied bitternut
pignut king nut shag bark
hickories pecan and then two inner
specific hybrids
uh dunbar's hickory which is shag bar
crossed with king nut
and nussbaum's heecan which is a pecan
hybridized with the king nut hickory
so we have a handful of taxa and the
data that i'll present today these data
were collected in 2019
and 2020 so they're all averaged over
two growing seasons to get a
better idea of the variability from year
to year
and we collected samples in the spring
and then in the summer for both years
all the plants are located in ithaca new
york with the exception of one
population of carie liciniosa which
was in moravia new york and we have nine
observations per
tree per season we can see the number of
trees that have contributed
to this data set and the methodology for
how we did this was a vapor pressure
osmometry
with corrections according to chaumont
edel and i'll talk about that on how we
did this on the next slide
data were subject to a one-way anova and
we used two keys hsd for mean
comparisons
okay so vapor pressure osmometry what is
it how are we doing it
well the idea here is we're going to
characterize drought tolerance using the
leaf water potential
at the turtle loss point so that's the
value that we're trying to predict
to get that we need to first get the
solute concentration of the leaves
in the spring and in the summer so
we start by one going to the site and
finding our plants that
comprise this data set and we collected
stems from those plants
in this growing season and we looked for
leaves that were
plants with leaves that were not
afflicted by disease they weren't
fruiting or flowering so they were
standardized
we removed them and cut them under water
and take them back to the laboratory
we left them in the laboratory covered
overnight and again they're they're cut
under water to remove embolism from the
stem and
the goal there is to let them get back
to full turtle
so the the stems are left to equilibrate
overnight the following day we would
come back in an image number three you
can see
that we use a seven millimeter cork
borer uh to get a leaf disc
the leaf disc is frozen in liquid
nitrogen to break down cellular barriers
and then we feed that into the vapor
pressure osmometer which gives us the
solute concentration value
solute concentration is then fed into
van hof's relation so we
we can calculate the osmotic potential
and in this case
uh full turgor because the plants were
allowed to equilibrate
and then we take advantage of this more
recent work that's been done by first
bartlett at all which they looked at a
global dataset
and created an equation for predicting
the leaf water potential of the trigger
loss point
using the osmotic potential value
and then we we use a refined equation
that is looking specifically at trees
that belong to the temperate region so
that we have
more accuracy and that equation was
developed by shimon at all
and so i have three slides of data i'm
going to show
i'm going to walk through what this how
you decipher this figure and then
that'll kind of tell us a little bit
more of what the results were and how
we've characterized drought tolerance
here
so what you're looking at are means of
the predicted leaf trigger loss point of
the species in hybrids
so that uh trigger loss point value is
negative megapascals is on the x-axis
you can think of it the more negative
the value the more drought-tolerant we
think that that plant would be
on the y-axis we have our species and
the species are ordered in descending
order
according to their summer means so the
summer means are represented in the
black bars and spring means are
represented with the gray bars
the overall across all the species and
all the plants
means are represented with those two
vertical lines for summer
and for spring so i just want to look at
the black bars today i want to look at
those summer means
um so these are the the means for that
predicted leaf trigger loss point
uh for all these species and what we can
see is that cardioglabra is up at the
top
that is our least drought tolerant
species and if we look at the bottom our
most drought tolerant was caria
liciniosa if we look at those species
and where they've kind of
segregated here on the y-axis we see
that our
uh riparian species are mostly at the
bottom of the y-axis and our upland
mesic species are mostly
up at the top now this scale is relative
and if we had looked at some of the
other data that was presented by
chaumont at all they've done this with
various trees that we might use in the
urban environment
we could take for example something like
acer platinoides the norway maple
a plant that's really tough and is a
very good urban tree
and if we looked at the mean for that
plant in summer we would find it right
around negative three
so relative to other trees that we know
to be very drought tolerant
all of these hickories are exceeding
that
but there are species that seem to be
better than others within our data set
we can look at the same general idea but
using two separate
uh populations so plants have known
provenance
and here we have plants of carrio
licinio so the king nut hickory
uh it was the species that had the the
greatest drought tolerance overall
in our last slide and if we look at
plants of known provenance in the
arboretum versus plants from a wild
population in moravia
we can see that provenance matters and
there's some variation there
we can also take this a step further and
look at our species cardioglebra the one
that was the least drought tolerant of
all of our species
and we can look at the number of
individual plants that
contributed to the data set so on the
y-axis you have the number of individual
trees that we looked at
and we can see that there's quite a bit
of variation just within that single
population of plants
mainly plants number one and eight on
the bottom of the y-axis
uh when we're looking at those black
bars seem to
have a greater capacity for drought
tolerance
than do plants 4 10 and and the other
ones up at the top
so there's a lot of variability even
within the populations
so the conclusions that we can draw from
this are the of the taxes that we
studied
carlos sineosa was the most drought
tolerant generally our riparian species
at least the ones that we looked at were
more drought tolerant than the upland
taxa
um again within this data set provenance
is of course important
and uh there's a significant amount of
variability even within populations
and so we think that this means if we
can find uh a good way of asexually
propagating these plants that clonal
selections could be made
that would be well suited to
drought-prone landscapes
on the note of asexual propagation that
is one of the projects
that we we looked at so we um trying to
look at something other than top
grafting finding a way to asexually
propagate hickories and dr
basic and urban horticulture institute
developed a modified stool bed layering
technique
that she used for her hybrid oak program
and so we thought well we could try this
and see if that works for species of
caria
the goal here with this experiment is
determining
if auxin concentration exogenous auxin
has a role in rootability of the plants
and so the species that we're looking at
are pecan king nut hickory and shagbark
hickory
our treatments are again those
concentrations of iba so
zero four thousand or eight thousand
parts per million
and then we have nine single uh stock
plant replicates
per treatment combination and uh
i'll go ahead and i'll walk through what
this process looks like
on the next slide so for those that may
not be familiar
with a mound layering um or specifically
this modified version of it
this is how we do it so we start with
plants that are established
in uh in the field so you can see that
on the far left these plants were
planted
let us to establish for a year and then
we came back
the following spring and we coppiced
them we stood them or cut them back
uh we let those plants uh bud out we
they formed
adventitious buds and once they reached
kind of that
stage that we see with the picture on
the right
we covered them with a light excluding
implement in this case we just used pots
that we had covered with foil
and the idea here is to exclude light so
that those shoots will ideolate
if once those shoots have idiolated to
about 10 centimeters tall which we see
in the middle there
we then apply exogenous auxin and this
is where we had either
zero parts per million four thousand or
eight thousand parts per million
oxen concentration and we applied that
to the base of those
ideolated shoots
we then mound those plants so we put a
soilless substrate along
um or we mound it up around them and
basically you want to cover where
we've painted the base of those shoots
with uh with oxen where we hope
roots will arise so we cover that with a
soilless substrate
and then we intro we transition those
plants back to full sun because they are
ideolated
we don't want them to to burn and so we
transition them with a shading implement
for approximately
two weeks now we did this on a
plant-by-plant basis
if if this was being implemented on a
larger scale in a
growers stock plant field maybe the same
clone would be in one row and they could
tarp all of them at once
but again because this is a research
project and each plant was a seedling
they're all at different times so we did
this on a case-by-case basis so you can
see
all the plants here in the field at the
bluegrass lane research center
and those plants are allowed to grow
throughout the summer and we revisit
them
in the fall so these plants we revisited
in october
right around when the leafs had leaves
had senesced
and we uncover the mounds and look at
the individual shoots which are called
layers
and we look to see if any roots have
formed where we had applied
our auxin or for the control just
ethanol
and then those layers can be removed
from the stock plant they can just be
cut away and that leaves you with rooted
layers and a happy graduate student so
you can see
of course a rooted shagbark hickory here
uh with a phenomenal root system
so we can look at the data here with
this table the
columns of this table from left to right
we're looking at the different taxes
that we studied
the auxin concentration the percentage
of rooting on a
stock plant basis and then the mean
count of roots per layer
a value kind of determining the quality
of rooting
uh so if it rooted how well did it how
many roots did you get
so we can look at the first two species
cartilaginoidensis and the sineosa
that's pecan and the king nut hickory
respectively
and we can see that with zero parts per
million auxin zero parts per million iba
we had no rooting
with four thousand and eight thousand
parts per million we did have rooting
almost identical responses for those
species at four thousand parts per
million
uh but with eight thousand parts per
million we had a higher rooting
percentage and a greater number of roots
per layer
with caria liciniosa if we compare that
to karya ovada
again the control resulted in no rooting
at all interestingly the 8 000 parts per
million
also resulted in no rooting but 4 000
parts per million was the sweet spot for
that species
and we had 95 percent rooting and 11.6
mean
uh count of roots per layer so a really
phenomenal response
with the shagbark hickory in that
situation so what do we take away from
this is that the exogenous auxin in this
setting
uh was necessary for rooting the
concentration is important
and it seems that the different species
respond to that concentration
differently
uh not just in rooting but also like we
noticed with shagbark hickory at 8 000
parts per million
a lot of those plants died so we think
that that oxen concentration was uh
phytotoxic uh the overall conclusions
and what we can take away is that the
modified stool bed layering technique
can be used to root species of caria and
that
asexual propagation techniques like this
open up opportunities for clonal
selections
and and basically alternatives to top
grafting
worth noting the roots of all of these
plants were fibrous they were not coarse
like a seedling of a comparable size and
so we question
if perhaps this root morphology has
implications for some of the other
generalizations and problems with these
trees that we see
in in nursery production
the other component that i mentioned was
that the the plants when grown from seed
are
slow to develop uh in the above ground
uh perspective so we wanted to determine
if plant growth regulators could be used
to modify
shoot growth in this case shoot
extension and so we looked at
gibberellic acid
uh we wanted to find out if gibralic
acid four plus seven
uh could influence shoot extension of
some hickories
and then we wanted to characterize it
and determine is this actually something
that could be useful
for nursery growers
so the species that we studied here are
bitternut
pignut shag bark king nut and mockernut
hickories and then we also have pecan
the treatments there are three
treatments they were either the control
which was untreated
or we had 500 parts per million
ga4 plus 7 dissolved in ethanol so we
have a ga
solution at 500 parts per million and
the two treatments there
is it was applied either to the apical
meristem which we called the bud
treatment
or it was applied to the basal region of
the chute
these plants were already two years old
coming into this study
and treatments were initiated in their
third growing season so right after they
were taken out of the coolers for their
winter dormancy
uh the buds were brought or they were
bought into the greenhouse
the buds swole became swollen and then
they broke
and that was when we started um to apply
ga4 plus seven
the way we did it was we just used a
cotton swab in
the ethanol solution in the ga solution
and we again applied it either to the
bud the apical meristem
or the basal region of the chute and we
did this at three day intervals for 27
days
we had 11 single plant replicates per
species in treatment
and the experiment lasted 160 days from
start to finish
i have a main effects table here uh
looking at two
factors that i want to share with you
today shoot extension and caliber
uh shoot extension we saw that the
factors there was an interaction between
species and treatment
um and then for caliper the the species
level was the only uh factor that was
important so
there was species variation for caliper
but the treatments had no effect on
caliper
and i want to start there with a
specific figure to look at the caliper
so again these are seedlings and so on
the x-axis we have the the different
species that we studied and on the
y-axis we have caliper and millimeters
again they're very small seedlings and
we're looking at caliper pooled across
treatments because species was the the
significant factor there
and what i want to convey here is that
there's variation
across these species that if we were to
only
look at one species that we're familiar
with like karya ovada
and conclude that um all the other
species must be very similar to that
well we'd be wrong
uh and so that's uh the point that i'm
trying to make here is that each species
should be considered on a case-by-case
basis when we're talking about
production in the nursery and use in
horticulture they each
are a little bit different and we
shouldn't generalize across the genus
now back onto the ga4 plus seven how did
those treatments
influence shoot extension on the x-axis
we have the species here and then on the
y-axis is shoot extension in centimeters
within each taxon group within each
species group
from left to right is the control stem
treatment and the bud treatment
if we look at the three species on the
right hand side
liceniosa ovada and tomentosa we can see
that those treatments didn't have any
effects
if we look at cardiac labra the species
second in from the left we can see a
trend but once again
nothing to write home about however if
we look at carya cortiformis and carya
ilinoanensis so bitternut hickory and
pecan
we can see that that bud treatment
resulted in a
very significant amount of shoot
extension
and so we can look at those plants in
particular uh on the left is bitterness
green on the right is pecan within each
picture control stem and bud treatments
and again that bud treatment uh the
plants almost
they they follow the graft pattern um
identically and so you can see the shoot
extension is is rather
important and large here with these two
species in particular
so what results and conclusions can we
draw from this well that bud
treatment with ga4 plus 7 resulted in a
234 percent increase of shoot extension
for bitterness hickory and a 144
increase
shoot extension for pecan neither of the
treatments
whether applied to the bud or to the
base of the stem
influenced caliper for any of the taxa
and
the two species that did respond may be
worth noting
both belong to the same sub-genus so
they're both considered
the pecan hickory group and
maybe that says something about the
mechanisms that are actually controlling
the episodic growth and uh and the shoot
development
it's worth noting that we tried this
experiment again with plants that had
already flushed
their growth for the season so in the
mid-summer once they had set a terminal
bud
we tried this exact experiment and we
were unable to induce a second
uh push a second flush of of growth in
one season and that was the original
hope
um but this is all kind of a jumping off
point for determining how we can use
plant growth regulators
to to influence plant growth in the
nursery
now for the last component here i'm not
going to go over any
data i'm going to use some pictures to
kind of tell the story
in the last experiment we were looking
at smaller plants uh smaller plants that
might be useful
for uh specialized growers who might
already be selling
like a trade gallon pot but what about
for everybody else people that
nursery growers that would be looking at
larger material and the larger material
that typically practitioners expect
for use in the landscape and we wanted
to look at how
hickories and pecan how they grew and
how they survived
containerization and field planting so
if you were a nursery grower
if you were growing plants in a
container nursery uh or in the field you
would purchase in what we call liners
so usually they're bare roots they're
smaller
these were whips they're 12 to 24 inch
tall plants they came from a forestry
nursery
they're harvested from a field with a
u-blade in the winter
they're shipped in the winter and then
in the spring you would either pot them
into the containers or you would line
them out in the field and so we designed
an experiment
uh looking at four different species to
examine how did those plants survive
both of these processes and we also
wanted to look at two different types of
containers the standard black plastic
and one of the new grow bags the root
maker
so we're looking at number 10 or trade
10 gallon sized
pots and then plants that are lined out
in the field
now the plants in the field i'm not
going to show an image of those because
they were just
so small compared to the plants that we
had in containers
uh the plants in the field have barely
grown over the three years that we've
looked at them
and whereas the plants in the containers
were leaps and bounds there were there
were big differences
and so i have some images here on the
bottom row we have the plants in the
grow bags and on the top row we have the
plants in the standard black plastic
the four species that we studied from
left to right are bitternut hickory
pecan king nut hickory and shag bark
hickory and
immediately what's apparent is that
there's a there's a difference
in uh the robustness of the plants in
the bottom row
compared to their plastic pot
counterparts above
and so we thought that was interesting
but what might again be more interesting
is the fact that the shag bark hickory
which is the plant
on the far right in both rows um they're
much smaller than their congeners
they're much smaller than the relatives
that we've looked at
and this picture was taken at the end of
year two of looking at these plants
and this was in the fall so the shagbark
hickories had already
uh senesced their leaves uh but you can
see they're they're basically still
a stick in a pot whereas the la uh
carrillo sineosa
pecan um and bitternut hickory
are much larger and so again this theme
of
this recurring theme of drawing
conclusions based on a species we're
familiar with for the whole genus
doesn't apply and so we think that in
this case the
bitternut hickory and the king nut
hickory could possibly be close to a
saleable size for a number 10 pot
product and this would only be a two
year investment for a container grower
so that was the end of year two and we
had this kind of strange phenomenon
in year three the plants had broken
their buds
and they started growing well but then
for our pecans and our bitternut hickory
in particular
we started to notice some really strange
symptoms that we couldn't really
attribute to any kind of management or
cultural practice so we ruled out
herbicide drift
we ruled out our well we were
fertilizing all the plants as we have
done for everything else
uh but again the bitternut hickory and
pecan developed these really strange
symptoms where the leaflet would curve
we had a necrotic margin and in some
cases the plants would rosette
so this kind of has most people
scratching their heads but this is where
a side project i had been working on the
year prior comes into
play where we were growing uh yellow and
sweet birch in 2019
these are plants that are again
underappreciated in horticulture and not
common in the nursery trade
dr basic wanted some for campus so that
we could teach in her plant materials
course creating the urban eden
yellow birch and sweet birch and so we
decided to grow some on our own
and in year two growing these plants in
soilless media
we started to see these strange symptoms
curling of the lamina
uh necrotic margin and it turned into a
rosetting
or kind of described as looking like a
witch's broom
so in 2019 we looked into this problem
we looked at the literature
and we found that these symptoms were
consistent with something called mousier
disorder
mouse ear disorder at least in the scope
of the nursery world
is only really documented with pecan and
river birch
it occurs with other plants it was
originally found with soybean
but for woody plants that we would find
growing in
in nurseries with soilless substrates
these two species
are notorious for exhibiting mouse ear
disorders so we can see the symptoms
on the right hand side and what is mouse
ear disorder mouse ear disorder is
essentially a function
of nickel deficiency so
when we're normally talking about nickel
with nickel being a heavy metal we're
usually talking about it in the sense of
phytotoxicity or too uh too much
but for a handful of plants and it seems
mostly these are urea transporting
species
they require possibly they require more
nickel but they definitely require some
nickel is is a necessary
nutrient for plant growth but these
plants seem to require a little bit more
the reason being is that nickel is a
essential co-factor for urease activity
urease activity will decline
when nickel is not supplied in adequate
amounts and urea builds up in the
tissues and that's what is thought to uh
to result in the curling of the leaves
the rosetting and the necrotic margin so
nickel nutrition turns out to be very
important for some of these birch
species
and at the time in 2019 i had reached
out to
john reuter at the university of georgia
who had done this work in the early
2000s with river birch
figuring out what the problem was and
how it's alleviated
and so we collaborated with him to
determine if the
commercial product nickel plus which is
a supplemental nickel product
could be used with yellow virgin sweet
birch right now the label is made
for uh
the label is for pecan and river birch
so we did this experiment and here we
have yellow birch on the left sweet
perch on the right
and from left to right within each image
you have the control twigs which are
symptomatic and then four twigs that
have been treated with nickel
and you can see with these birch that
the nickel alleviated the problem
um and so this work will be published
this year uh
and ultimately what this did for us was
give us a leg up in figuring out what
was probably also happening with our
hickories
the symptoms were very much the same and
as i said in the literature pecan is
notorious for having this issue
so now we are uh looking through the
other species of caria to figure out
which ones
may also be susceptible and this general
nutrition component will be important
for nursery growers
in developing this crop and we did see
it like i said mostly on bitternut
hickory and on pecan but we've also
found it
um on most of the other species that
we've worked with
and so this work is ongoing and our
preliminary trials have
suggested that that is exactly what's
going on that this mouse ear disorder
which we originally found with our
yellow and sweet birch
also is happening with our with our
hickories
so that work is ongoing uh the other
project that i
uh i'm not going to be able to talk in
detail about today
is going is ongoing and we're collecting
data this spring to wrap this project up
is the effects of species size and
production technique
on the transplanting or
transplantability of four species of
caria
we were really lucky to get this
experimental crop of shag bark hickory
from
uh nursery and you can see them here
either in bare root with the plastic
bags or bald and burlapped and there are
large plants
uh when i spoke with the company these
plants i think were in the ground for 14
years to get to this size
so we we really lucked out and uh in
timing
and uh dr bowerly has been uh helping me
with looking at different ways of
measuring new root growth
with those inground soil cores that we
see there and
ultimately we're looking at root
hydraulic conductance and
general uh growth responses to try to
figure out how
those effects of species size and
production technique affect
uh transplant success and i have an
image on the right of
dr basic and ryan georgia we were
admiring a tree that we'd planted
earlier
uh last spring and i really appreciated
their help because this was
in the early stages of covid when
everything was uh was still rather
complicated
but we were able to safely continue with
our research
so we hope to have those data
at the end of this year and published
and so hopefully we can
contribute to that area of transplanting
that area of the problem with hickories
and looking forward so how do we take
all this information that i've mentioned
so far
um and continue to develop hickories as
crops
uh from either my perspective or the
perspective
perspectives of other and other people
in horticulture and and beyond
well we of course can refine and modify
the techniques that i've talked about
today
under the categories of propagation
production and transplanting
uh this is really a jumping off point i
think we've made some really good
progress
um but some of these techniques can be
modified for
you know becoming more applicable to
other nursery settings
those that have interest in selection
and breeding could
really take advantage of an opportunity
here where we have
so many species so many unique
provenances and so many traits that
could be bred for
and cultivars clonal cultivars selected
for and
mainly i'm thinking ornamental traits
which is obvious
expanded application all these trees
produce nuts
and you know we could look at the
variability in nut size
usually for nut production you want a
larger fruit that's easier to crack and
taste good
but maybe for some of our urban examples
we might want a smaller
fruit size or less fruit
that's that's produced on an annual
basis so that they
aren't considered a nuisance in some
situations maybe for high traffic urban
areas
we can look for plants that are suited
to production i had shown the images of
the variability
in the the field at schicktel's nursery
and so we could have cultivars that are
just more uniform
uh clones that we could have more like i
said uniformity and less variability in
production
and when i talked about the drought
tolerance we talked about
how some plants individual plants uh
seem to be
more stress tolerant in the way of uh of
drought stress and drought tolerance so
we could be selecting plants um from
that perspective as well
and then i want to mention also
germplasm and conservation that uh
botanic gardens arboreta
and public uh institutions like the usda
germplasm repositories play an important
role in not only preserving the genetics
that we have but
in preserving the the beauty of these
plants going forward
and with any luck with some of this
information and
with a little bit more future research
plants like this shagbark hickory
will become the norm they'll be a lot
more popular
in a park street tree planting or maybe
even in your own
backyard so i'd like to share here just
the sources that i've talked about
some of those um literature sources and
then
some web images that i've borrowed or
modified
and before i finish up i just want to
acknowledge some institutions and some
people of course the funding
organizations
mcintyre usda nifa mcintyre stennis
the horticultural research institute i'd
like to thank the
institutions that have housed this work
cornell uh university cornell cals and
sips
we work with john reuter with the birch
work and he's from the university of
georgia there have been industry
collaborators with all of this that have
been uh
very helpful naipan uh provided nickel
plus
uh the nickel supplement to us
shikhtel's nursery has been
very helpful and jim kisker in
particular
saved the day in the early days of covid
when i couldn't travel to the nursery to
acquire samples and he really helped us
out a lot
jean grace pride's corner dr bowerly for
helping with the
in-ground soil cores the research
assistants and technicians
have been incredibly helpful hazel
eileen
jimmy nina fanfang and ryan georgia and
last but certainly not least my research
committee and my advisor
my advisor nina basic has made this work
possible and i can't thank her enough
for all of her help
and like i said just making this
opportunity available for me
to study this area that i'm so
passionate about and
dr mark bridgen and dr tim setter for
their help they've been incredibly
helpful
and supportive of me in any way that
they can throughout
throughout my phd so i'd like to say
thank you to all those people
and and there are other people for other
projects i haven't talked about but
you all know who you are and i
appreciate all of your help
and with that i would just like to say
thank you to all of you for listening to
this presentation today
and uh i'd like to go ahead and if we
have any time left to take any questions
uh brandon may i start out with a
with an easy question for you sure um
i i thought your findings using the
vapor pressure osmometry were very nice
but i i do have a question about the
spring versus summer
measurements and i'm wondering
uh how long after leaf
expansion were those specimens in the
spring taken was it very shortly after
expansion or was it after a few weeks
yeah that's a great question so uh these
were taken
so it was you could consider it
mid-spring the reason i chose mid-spring
is that that was
at the time that all of those plants
that i studied
they had all completely expanded uh
their their initial growth the first at
least the first few leaves of their
initial growth
so uh it was shortly after expansion but
not
um not too close to blood break if that
makes sense
so i i think it was late may or the
first week of june
is when i had done it here um so they
had fully expanded but um
those first few leaves had fully
expanded would you
would you say that they had fully
greened up
or were they still in the greening up
phase yeah
they definitely had fully they were
fully greened up um
i i went more towards fully developed
than
uh less developed and the idea there was
that we could get a baseline once they
had fully expanded
uh to compare what they were uh fresh
for the growing season compared to
after they had endured um the conditions
of the growing season in the summer
great thank you thank you
looks like there's a question in the
chat
so the question i'm seeing in the chat
is that they think they've seen
the mouse ear disorder and persimmon
also is this something i've come across
and it happens when they use less aged
pine fine growing media
yes it is definitely possible to happen
to other plants and i have seen it on
persimmon that i've grown myself
i had seedlings of persimmon that uh
had the same issue and we treated it
with nickel plus and and that worked as
well
so there are other plants that
definitely could have this problem and i
know for a fact that persimmon is
um it's not documented but uh is
definitely something to think about they
the literature suggests it's plants that
are
uh they tend to be urea transporters and
also a lot of these plants tend to be
riparian
or plants that you'd find in uh more wet
locations so
i'm not sure if that's always the case
but it might be
um useful for predicting which taxa
could have this problem
this is the frank schroeder from
chemistry i'm i'm
i think here because i actually grow
hickory trees a little bit as a hobby
and i really enjoyed learning so much
more about them um i have
one comment in one question so i have
one tree in my yard of
30 trees it clearly has the most ear
disease and i've wondered for years what
that is
and i'll try a nickel treatment see see
if it changes things they're pretty big
tree
uh not big it's it's a medium sized tree
maybe
six inch diameter or so and i noticed
that they really respond to nitrogen a
lot in in you know the young trees
the grafts that i've planted and uh
maybe reflecting your results as well so
pecan and
shell bark or king nut they really
respond very well to nitrogen you can
get two or three feet of growth in a
year now
right um but the ovada the shack bark
is the slowest you know it's always the
slowest
even though once they're large you know
i have older trees that grow two feet a
year but the young ones are small
yeah the the juvenile phase is
definitely part of it they're
they're the absolute slowest when
they're juvenile uh but once they kind
of
reach that um past that juvenile phase
there seems to be a switch
and like you mentioned the uh king nut
or shell bar kicker in pecan
once they they get to that point then
they'll put on multiple feet of growth
in one one uh shoot expansion one season
and i agree that they are they do appear
to be heavy nitrogen feeders as well
there's another question in the chat
from ken mudge about why we think the
riparian species would be more drought
resistant
than the upland species it's
counter-intuitive
drought tolerant is what we're aiming
for here and yes it is counterintuitive
but um when you look at like i said when
you look at some of these riparian
habitats
sometimes they are more inundated and
wet
throughout the year but some riparian
habitats uh
they go through they're on the edge and
they go through a fluctuation between
inundation
and sometimes they'll go through
seasonal droughts um and in swamps that
actually tends to be the case if you
look at like texodium in the wild
sometimes a year they're a couple feet
under water and sometimes of the year
it's completely bone dry
uh in in the middle of the summer and so
there's other
there's an other area a body of work
that's been exploring this that for some
well although it's counterintuitive uh
that those plants are
actually sometimes better adapted to to
fluctuations and so that's why we
wondered if they'd be better
suited to uh to drought and the plants
that we looked at from mezic sites
aren't necessarily locations that get
really really dry
routinely like those weren't species
that we would find on like rocky
outcroppings for example
i think that if we target other species
that might be
on really dry sites that you know we
find evidence that those plants
could also be very drought tolerant but
again the idea with the plants from
riparian habitats is we might have
two birds one stone that could be um
capable of tolerating the spectrum
back and forth between flooding and
drought
brandon first of all terrific seminar
and really well-developed research so
congratulations
on that thank you given that
the vegetatively propagated ideolated
um plants showed a
more fibrous root system than do
seedlings might they be better adapted
for
planting in shallow rooted or
hard pan sites
would they be better for shallow sites
that's an excellent question
i don't know that a uh shallow rooted
fibrous root system would be better for
a hard pan site
i actually think perhaps the the plant
that has the taproot and maybe the
sinker roots could be a better
um could be if they if they can reach
the deeper
soil horizon um but i think maybe it
depends on the perspective in the
context i think if uh
if that uh hard pan is not penetrable by
roots
um then could the fibrous one do well i
think it could and i think really
the reason i'm saying that is less of
the morphology but more of the fact that
it seems that these plants are able to
tolerate drought not just resist drought
or avoid drought
but they can tolerate it so that's a
good question i think i need to do a
little more work
to try to get a better answer but but i
think it really depends on the context
of if the roots can penetrate past
the hard pan because these plants are
known for having a really strong
aggressive root system that other tree
species
uh may not be in that same
ranking if you will one of the things
that
we talked about is the difference in
morphology
of the asexually propagated plants may
make them
more amenable to transplanting so we
have yet to look at that
right yeah they it could be that any of
the issues that might have led to
generalizations with taproots
could be alleviated with those fibrous
root systems
more questions i have one more quick
question
about the propagation what happens if i
now just make a cutting and put oxen on
it and put it into media in my
greenhouse
i haven't done it i was going to do it
this spring just to see if any of them
would root
just you know sausages growth cut off
and put right now is a good time i think
for apples at least some other things to
do there
so so the question so the question is
looking at just other forms of
vegetative products
people probably tried it i i just wanted
to know from you if you've tried it
yeah so it's definitely been tried i've
tried it myself
it's usually unsuccessful some of the
pecan literatures suggest that
dormant hardwood cuttings could be
possible but the rooting percentage is
really low
and i have not seen any evidence and nor
have i been able to do it myself with
soft wood
or semi hardwood cuttings cuttings
really seem to be more difficult
and the benefit to like that modified
layering technique is
not only are we taking advantage of
exogenous auxin
the plants are still connected to the
mother plant and
but they're also juvenile tissue so
because they're
coppiced it's juvenile tissue so those
are all kind of added bonuses to
in the general sense thinking about
which factors might help
boost routability um so you kind of
check all the boxes
with with that technique
thanks yeah absolutely uh hi brandon
wonderful talk nice to see you again
here i just saw i wanted to ask about
like regarding the shack but hickory
with its very poor
growth weight as a ceiling so i was
wondering if this might have something
to do with its ecological niche like
maybe they're very like shade dependent
when they're young uh did you look into
that possibility and another question
was uh
also kind of related but possibly the
role of a microvisor
and microvisor associations in uh
transplanting
or even like the growth of seedlings
yeah that's a great that's a great
question so
most of the hickories if you look at
forestry literature are known to be very
dr
uh shade tolerant so these are plants
that will have to compete in heavy shade
and uh you are you're probably right
there that part of the sequence
is being able to survive that
that period uh one way that you could
look at it is they put all this energy
into the tap root
uh hickories are notorious for being
able to re-sprout and so
deer brows is a big problem in a lot of
the the habitats that you find them
so seedlings could be browsed back many
many times
but if they have their energy stored in
the taproot they're more capable
of being able to re-sprout and try again
or
like you've mentioned with shading
waiting for their moment
for light to open up in the canopy and
they can go forth
you can try them in shade or in the sun
uh
in a production setting shag marks in
particular it doesn't change
the the growth not that much you get a
little bit of shoot extension
uh but not you know they still go
through that period uh episodic growth
and you know the differences are
centimeters if anything at all
uh the second question about
associations
yes i have not done any work with
associations mycorrhizal associations
but i know for a fact that the
cardiologist the king nut hickory
uh it is known to have an
ectomycorrhizal association and i can't
think of which
organism in particular but i think with
most plants
whether we have it documented or not
there's probably a bunch
of associations that are going on um
however i do know there is one
noted example for the uh carila sineosa
that riparian species
thank you yeah great questions so are we
up done
i think so okay so uh thanks so much
brandon it's always a pleasure
and um i really appreciate giving your
full viewpoint here today wonderful all
right thank you all very much
take care bye bye take care
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu